when you originally location scouting
you found this place in tucson in this
house well it was even before I would
say location scouting it was just I knew
you know that you know with family ties
to this location that we could go shoot
there and so that way you know I knew I
had a window of a few months were I
thought well I can i can go shoot
something here and so I had been playing
around with some ideas for this location
for a little while and then sort of
these months came where I was like okay
this is the time to do it and really you
know kicked it into gear and you know
just decided okay we have to make this
happen and how were you received in in
Tucson versus may be shooting something
in la a short film maybe you've done in
the past I mean yes it's a pretty big
difference for you know people being
excited to to lend a location or you
know we have like it I mean we shot it
you know the big one of the biggest
hospitals in Tucson we had a bunch of
scenes and and they just kind of let us
go all over the hospital you know for a
whole day and night and the new yeah I
mean it was kind of crazy the access we
had to this place and
and it was just a matter of you know
getting in touch with the right people
and was able to you know be in tucson
you were able to get past that first
level a lot easier than in LA I mean
certainly in la you could do that but
you know you would you know we didn't
pay for it and Tucson so yeah there's
there's a given you know there's a
give-and-take to Emma being in la
affords a lot of opportunities at being
in a place like Tucson you know doesn't
have I also in terms of just
infrastructure of actors and crew and
and all that so it's you know but for
this kind of movie that was small and
you know wasn't a huge number of
locations it hit town you know it was
yeah it was manageable for sure
you